and joining us right now is one of our
favorites covering uh the nba
from the worldwide leader in sports
kendrick perkins of espn back here on
the show how are you kendrick
what's going on rich appreciate you
having me man always you know that
uh so i'll give you the floor first the
news on kawhi leonard being
out uh what appears to be significantly
would mean what for the clippers i mean
that this
series is over in six and i and i hate
to say it that way but you know i just
got to keep it real at all times with
you rich every time i come on
show look the kawaii the
los angeles clippers are not going
anywhere if they don't have kawhi
leonard they especially
are not beating the utah jazz i had this
series going seven games anyway
but now it's going six i mean because i
don't think hawaii is coming back
i think it's more serious than what
people are saying and i don't know if
paul
george is that batman that could carry
this team and go
toe-to-toe with donovan mitchell we all
know how utah plays at home
they're going to come out fired up
tonight role players are going to play
better that crowd is going to be
electrified
i just hate it for kawhi leonard because
he had he was starting to rise to the
occasion
and started to show us that kawhi
leonard joy and he had just had one of
the best dogs
if not the best dogs in the playoffs and
then here it is he goes out
it's really bad for the for the game of
basketball for all the fans because
you know in a perfect world we would
like to see the nets and clippers in the
finals
but it's not going to happen if kawhi
lennon is injured what do you think is
happening and wherever the clippers are
in that hotel room in utah getting ready
to play tonight what do you
what does ty lue even say to this team
do you think well
i mean one thing about tyler is that
he's not going to shy away from the
he's not going to shy away from the
moment uh he's the guy that is gonna go
out there and he's gonna coach his tail
off he's gonna preach and say hey look
next man up i get it paul george what
are you gonna
do he's gonna call out reggie jackson
he's gonna make the adjustments
he's gonna put guys in position to be
successful
it's on them whether or not they're
going to do it but he's going to have
them prepared
mentally he's going to lead the charge
he's not going to shy away from the
moment
he's going to tell guys hey look
nobody's going to feel sorry for us
what you gonna do who's gonna step up
he's gonna challenge those guys
but even you a 14-year nba veteran
kendrick and you've been through
uh thick and thin and you've won one i
mean
you you just basically wrapped it up i
mean you stuck a fork in him and i think
everybody is too and you could maybe
utilize that but
i mean the players have it'll be a tough
one to believe
it'll be a tough one to buy from the
coach i would think
it would rich but i'm gonna give you a
scenario right
in 2008 2009 kg got hurt
and we didn't have them for the playoffs
but in our mind we
we were saying hey forget that we about
to go out here and compete and we
actually took the orlando magic to seven
games who
they end up winning the eastern
conference and going to the finals after
but and then getting swept by the los
angeles lakers
but at the end of the day you know it's
about your mentality
it's about having that dog in you if you
ain't got that dog in you then you got a
problem
kendrick perkins espn hoop stream's
co-host as well
as uh nba analyst on a host of espn
programs right here
on the rich eisen show what do you think
chris paul's thinking right now
what are you hearing about that kendrick
you know it's unfortunate and i don't
get it he's vaccinated right
i just don't i don't understand
everything that's going on i don't know
the process
i don't know you know if you're
vaccinated how long you have to stay in
protocol the good thing
about it for the suns is that they
handled their business
early right so i mean it buys chris paul
a few days
um and he needs to rest anyway dealing
with the injuries and his shoulder but
not being able to be around his
teammates not being able to be in that
film room
and be that leader and study in that
film room
it's going to kind of hurt the sons a
little bit because you have to
understand
as remarkable as chris paul has been on
the court
his leadership is unmatched and is is
invaluable
for his leadership for us him you know
you read those stories about how
all the guys go to his house to have
dinner and watch the games together and
that camaraderie and at this moment in
time when you're
headed into the western conference
finals and you're about to
possibly face a powerhouse like the utah
jazz or the los angeles clippers you
need your leaders so
hopefully you know the clippers push
this to seven games
and it could spare chris paul a little
bit more time but
it's going to hurt the suns a little bit
i don't think dramatically
i think they're locked in uh but i think
overall you know you just hate to hear
this news because
the suns were vibing so well and cp3 was
on the mission
he still is on the mission i mean let's
be honest kendrick i mean if
as you just and i think rightfully so
stuck a fork in the clippers because
kawhi is out um
for the rest of the series and then
perhaps for
a long time after that with an acl
injury as it's being rumored and
reported right now
that we're going to see the western
conference finals start sooner
rather than later and if that costs even
chris paul one game
certainly in utah that will hobble the
sun's opportunity
uh to gain home court advantage for for
themselves now that fans are all back in
there
but uh let's place that aside even for a
moment
and and i i want to pull on that string
you you just laid out there about
chris not being there in a film room and
not there
physically with the players and his
teammates as they
are going through the paces to get ready
what what does that look like
a film room in the nba with somebody
like chris paul sitting
in it what is that what does that look
like you just you just
adding you add another coach right so
when the film see people don't
understand and and
this is a conversation another
conversation that we can have on another
time
but when i when i made the comparison
and i said that
you know people think that it's easy to
win the nba
championship is not and and and i made a
comparison for us with football
and football players were telling me how
much film room how much studying they
have to do
the play books the film room well when
you're in the playoffs
guess what you having two hour film
sessions
so as coach money is sitting there
talking
and coach money is going through things
and saying hey
we need to do this you may have a
veteran like chris paul because i've
done it at times
i might say well hey coach money you may
have chris paul say hey coach money
i don't know i don't think we should we
should we should uh drop being a drop
coverage defensively
and now you have an ongoing situation
where you have a conversation
within the locker room and now it's like
okay now coach manny is feeling or or
chris paul may say
hey i don't think devin booker should be
guarding
joe ingles i think he should be guarding
bondanovich and then they have a
discussion this is the things that
happen in the film room
when you have a leader like chris paul
is on the floor all
coach money may say well what we're
going to do offensively is i want to do
x
y and z well cp3 may say coach well look
let's do this but make sure let's tweak
this so that we could get devin booker
this flare on the weak side like
all this happens during the course of a
film room
especially when you're a leader the
voice of the the voice of the team
is in there you have back and forth but
it's positive energy
because everybody's just trying to get
on the same page so they can attack that
series or their game like they need to
kendrick perkins of espn right here on
the rich eisen show
um so i i know this is kind of a
maybe uh an infused way to ask this
question certainly with durant
going off for 49 and 17 and 10 and you
know
the patrick beverly lou williams sound
bite from
when durant got the clippers a couple
years ago about how they come they
couldn't stop him and they both said
well he's kevin durant
so i i know that uh when i asked this
question
that i think is fair though what are the
bucks missing
kendrick perkins it seems like there's
just one extra gear
that's missing with this team or player
or something
what do you see when you look at the
bucks on that front
i see i see a i see a dumb team and i
and i say that respectfully
they're missing the iq like i'm watching
the game last night
one example okay drew holiday comes down
okay james harden is guarding him he
takes him off the dribble
and goes to the basket with ease and
finish with a left hand later
all right the next possession down they
get a stop
he comes down the very next place we all
know
james harden didn't look 50 out there
last night he couldn't move
and you know what drew holiday does he
pulls up for a jump shot
and i'm watching some of the plays the
careless turnovers
by chris millerson and even giannis like
the shot selection the timing like the
possessions and
valuing possessions and you know just
some of the shot selection i'm just like
they're missing the iq all across the
board
i'm watching this talented athletic team
just going out there and play like that
at rutgers park and there's nothing
really that a coach could do
it's the players like bud can put them
out there and call plays and put guys in
position to be successful
but as a player if you don't have that
basketball iq
if you don't have that sense of urgency
then it's not going to work
and what we saw yesterday we saw james
harden
and kevin durant show their iq
and show how much of a floor generals
that they were
they were head and shoulders above the
milwaukee books
they're not the milwaukee bucks are not
lacking anything
talent wise they have everything that
they need
it's their minds and i'm sitting up here
saying like why did you try to throw
that pass do you understand this is the
playoffs
do you understand that people study
these certain reads and that they want
you
they bait you into thinking that this is
this
past is open but it's really not and i'm
sitting there watching i'm like
what are y'all doing like they haven't
the brooklyn nets haven't stopped the
milwaukee bucks from getting to the
paint
at all but yet they still they settle
for jump shot after jump shot at the
jump side
and it's hard to watch well but coach
budd comes from
as we all know pop uh tree and so you
know
what you're saying can't be news to to
the coaching staff how do you fix it
how's that fixable i i don't know i mean
like you could drill it
you could drill it you could go to film
room you could call out certain plays
you could tell them
you cannot do these turnovers this can't
happen
that can't happen and if they go out
there and still do the same thing
it's like as as coach but you like what
am i supposed to do
if you're trying to tell giannis hey
giannis how about setting a pick and
roll
get a ball up early go into a quick
dribble handoff
roll to the basket how about this
giannis they want you to take jumpers
they want you to make a jump shot you
know why because
the brooklyn nets when when giannis
makes a jump shot
watch the brooklyn in this [ __ ] they
start clapping
you know why because it's bait it's bait
because they want him to take more jump
shots so if i'm if i'm cold
boo knows if i bud i i don't i don't
really know what to say yourself
hey guys let's go out here and play hard
let's go out here hope that we make
shots because
the iq is not there
love it i mean this is why i love having
you on kendrick before
before i let you go uh seriously
uh best of three in with the uh
sixers and the hawks hawks have a shot
here do you give them a chance yet
what do you think they do i believe it's
going seven games
oh and here's why i think you know when
philly dropped the ball
not closing out game five joel and b
didn't look healthy in that second half
now
how he comes on game six they'll be at
home
obviously the fans will be behind them
the role players will play
better but it goes back to the milwaukee
bucks point
the philadelphia 76ers did not play
smart basketball
in the second half and guess who they
were missing
a guy that probably nobody thought that
was that valuable to their team
a three-time champion that's on the
sideline
that that wasn't there and that's danny
green see people take
veterans people take leadership for
granted but it is so valuable when
you're trying to win a championship
that you have a leader someone that has
been through the trenches someone that
is battle tested
to be on the court so you could value
possessions
and that's what i watched out of philly
so with danny green being
out i'm looking at the hawks and the
sisters and this
is basically like the same thing it's
two young teams
with a lot of young players that's going
back and forth to say
i'm out score you or you go out scoring
me let's see
because right now it's no sense of
urgency defensively
on either part so what i'm looking at
right now the hawks have a lot of
momentum
the hawks feeling good about themselves
and i see this game going i see this
series going seven games i really do
i love it last one for you kendrick
pacer's job is open
but so is the job to be the coach of
tatum and jaylen brown in boston
damien lillard in portland you've got
now
bradley beal and russ in dc that job is
opens that
the job to coach zion and ingram and
lonzo is open which one would you want
if you're a head coach and you have an
opportunity and which one would you take
which is the most well rich i'm not
saying this because uh you know i'm not
being biased
oh you're a celtics but i i'm i'm going
with those two young superstars over
there in boston
with jason tatum and jaylen brown look
one thing
one thing about it is that in in today's
game
coaches it's like almost coach's pawn
to be able to have two guys at the wing
position like that
two guys that could go out there and get
you 25 a night
really have zero flaws and they are
under the age of 25
they're locked into contract they both
could play on the defensive end at a
high level
6-7 one of them 6-10 super athletic both
of them i mean like and they keep
getting better
that's the attractive job if i'm a coach
right now
that's the job that i want to go get is
that celtic job
kendrick thanks for the time uh look for
my call again
seriously i really do you make me
smarter and it's entertaining
and informative and um you're terrific
thanks for the call
rich thank you legend i appreciate you
having me appreciate it you got it it's
kendrick perkins i follow him on twitter
you need to you need to see his
real-time commentary that's for sure
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here